in a town that's synonymous with the
railways past this is very much its
present it seems likely to be the
immediate future too the strike by train
drivers and support staff left crew
station almost deserted
across the country cancellations
shutting down much of the mainline
Network among the handful of passengers
waiting for one of the few trains though
it was support for the strikers I think
that they have a need to do it because
I've been a worker all my life in terms
of the personal way it's affected me
I've had to wait an hour on this station
I'm freezing to death and I don't feel
very well but other than that I think
they've got the right to do it and I'm
sad that they have to do it in this day
and age
at Birmingham New Street the platforms
were also empty the cost of a dispute
over pay and conditions that remains
deadlocked and this just the start of
days of strike action across rail unions
and stretching into the weekend and
train drivers not backing down still
going as long as it takes unfortunately
I think we're in it for Long Haul now
um people don't seem to realize that we
haven't had a pay rise for three years
it's not just this year and we're not
seeking the two years during the
pandemic because the cost of living
crisis we're looking at something
realistic for this year what is perhaps
most concerning for passengers is how
far away a solution seems the
conversations that we're having in the
room with the unions are are productive
but they are moving much slower than I
think anyone would like and with train
travel simply not an option for so many
people on days like this exactly what
you'd expect to happen on the roads is
now happening
the level of traffic congestion was up
in and around London but measurements of
how much longer Journeys were taking
compared to free-flowing traffic were
most striking in the north of England
Manchester saw its congestion level
reach 116 at 9am up from 80 percent the
same time last week in Sheffield the
congestion level was 74 up from 58 a
week ago and in Liverpool the level Rose
from 60 to 75.
the government says these strikes punish
the people unions claim to stand up for
but one of those unions has warned of a
winter of rail misery ahead Greg Milam
Sky News crew